thank you
[Music]
tomorrow
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Sun exploded tomorrow
that star at the center of our solar
system that super hot ball of plasma
that gives us heat and energy and
amazing complexions
well
it's a ticking time bomb
the sun is four and a half billion years
old but it's only expected to last about
another 5 billion years
after that the sun will expand becoming
a red giant
then it will shrink to become a white
dwarf
a dying star cooling for the next
several billion years
of course we'll all be long gone before
any of that happens but
still can you imagine what it would be
like to watch the sun blow up before
your very eyes
with a name like Supernova you'd think
that a solar explosion would be the most
magnificent fireworks show the world has
ever seen
but in reality he likely wouldn't see
anything
the sun is 150 million kilometers away
from Earth
and it takes eight minutes for light
from the sun to reach us
and while that may seem super far away
in Supernova terms we don't stand a
chance
for Earth to be completely safe from a
supernova we'd need to be at least 50 to
100 light years away
but the good news is that if the sun
were to explode tomorrow the resulting
shock wave wouldn't be strong enough to
destroy the whole earth only the side
facing the sun would boil away instantly
the lucky other half would experience a
rise in temperature that would be 15
times hotter than the sun's current
surface temperature
and permanent Darkness
and without the Sun's mass keeping us in
orbit Earth would likely start floating
off into space
while its remaining inhabitants
desperately struggle to stay alive
there is a chance that our planet could
lock into orbit around another star that
might provide the same light and heat as
our sun
but by the time that happened we'd all
be long gone
if we knew in advance the day that the
sun would explode
then we could buy ourselves as many as
one thousand years of time provided we
had the resources to sustain ourselves
for that long
and we could
just a few meters below the ground you
walk on the earth is maintaining a
temperature of about 17 degrees
so if we had enough time to prepare
civilization could continue to live by
moving underground into a huge network
of fortified bunkers
within a week after the explosion the
surface temperature on Earth would drop
to -18 degrees
within a year temperatures would plummet
to about -73 degrees at this point the
oceans would begin to freeze from the
top down within one thousand years
Earth's atmosphere would freeze and
collapse
leaving anything left on the surface
exposed to Cosmic radiation and meteor
impacts hopefully by that point we'd
have found ourselves a new home
the good news is that if the sun were to
explode and it will eventually happen it
wouldn't happen overnight
when the sun does die it will be a long
slow arduous process taking place over
billions of years
the sun will get hotter and brighter and
it will start to expand during this
process it will lose its outer layers to
the cosmos leading to the creation of
other stars and planets in the same way
that the Violet burst of the Big Bang
created Earth
who knows maybe New Life Could form can
you imagine another Earth a new humanoid
species
it's hard to predict how our galaxy
might look billions of years from now
and it's especially hard to imagine our
solar system without the great Golden
Anchor that keeps us all together but
one day in the very very distant future
the sun will expand and then it will
shrink maybe leaving room for a new star
to take its place
trees are falling
ecosystems are collapsing
and our infrastructure is crumbling
crops are failing and water is scarce
Earth is becoming a dead planet on the
plus side there's never been a better
time to buy property
but who can think about real estate when
they can't leave their own home let
alone get out of bed
let alone breathe
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Earth was as big as the
sun
everyone knows the sun is big I mean
look at it and that's just how big it
looks from about 150 million kilometers
away
imagine what it would look like if you
were standing next to it
[Music]
never mind the sun accounts for 98 of
the mass of our entire solar system
and compared to the densest Planet which
is our very own planet Earth
the sun is more than a million times
more massive
in fact it would take roughly one
million three hundred thousand Planet
Earths to fill the entire Sun but what
if it only took one
Earth would be a very different place if
it were the same size as the sun just
imagine our whole planet's topography
being stretched out
continents would expand providing much
needed relief in places where
overpopulation inhibits the quality of
life and owning a nice plot of land
might actually be more affordable than
it is on today's planet Earth
but now we'd also have to consider that
every body of water on our planet would
have more area to cover this means that
lakes rivers and even the oceans would
be shallower making them more
susceptible to evaporation and
potentially drying out
marine life would undoubtedly suffer
since shallower water would gain more
heat from the Sun
jeopardizing sea creatures that need
colder water to survive with other
smaller water sources beginning to dry
up Wildlife on land might have to
relocate or travel much farther for
fresh water which would also put them at
risk us humans would be in an equally
precarious position Not only would we
probably start fighting over the limited
fresh water that's available our food
crop yields would also start shrinking
food crops need a certain amount of soil
to grow in and to absorb the nutrients
they need
if our world was as big as the sun then
like the water our soil would have to be
spread out to cover a much larger space
less soil would mean less food
while the demand for food would stay the
same
there's also another issue that we
haven't considered which when we Factor
it in makes life on Earth pretty much
impossible
Earth being the same size as the sun is
hard enough to imagine but when you
consider a sun-sized earth having the
same mass as the sun
it doesn't only jeopardize our survival
it disrupts our entire solar system
think about it with the Earth as big as
the sun you'd pretty much lose the moon
either way
but if a planet has more mass it will
also have a stronger gravitational pull
in this case gravity on Earth would be
28 times as strong as it is now
we'll get to how this affects you in a
moment but first let's look at the
bigger picture
the reason why our solar system moves
the way it does now is because the Sun's
mass is so great
its gravitational pull forces other
planets into its orbit the sun currently
has 98 percent of the mass in our entire
solar system but now the Sun and the
Earth would each have 49 of the mass in
our solar system would this result in
some sort of binary system in which the
Sun and the Earth orbited each other
how would this new rivalry affect the
orbits of the other planets in our solar
system and would a significantly higher
gravitational pull mean that Earth would
get hit by a lot more asteroids well
there'd be a lot more to worry about
than just asteroids
our satellites would also probably crash
down to earth while buildings and
bridges would crumble and collapse under
the increased gravitational pressure
only thick trees that were low to the
ground would remain standing but it's
unlikely that much else could shoulder
the added wave
you would be significantly heavier and
you probably wouldn't be able to walk
anywhere
think about it if you weigh 50 kilograms
on Earth right now it would feel like
you weighed 1400 kilograms on a
sun-sized earth the cruel twist is that
as gravity increases time would slow
down so you might be able to live longer
but it would probably be a long life
spent lying in bed with aches and pains
luckily we can wake up from this
nightmare because the Earth will never
be as big as the sun in fact our planet
is actually getting smaller our
atmosphere leaks and so we end up losing
several hundred tons of Mass to space
every day
so take a nice deep breath and be glad
it's that easy it's not always a good
idea to mess with proportions and bigger
definitely doesn't always mean better
with the vastness of the universe
everything in it seems so spread out
but some objects are closer than you
might realize
every now and then a random Interstellar
asteroid passes through the Oort cloud
the wall of icy debris at the very edge
of our solar system but what if a rogue
star unceremoniously rampaged right
through the Oort cloud
how bad would it be if it brought other
planets along for the ride
this is what if and here's what would
happen if another star entered our solar
system
what if I told you that a rogue star has
already invaded our son's territory
a dim Red Dwarf dubbed Schultz's star
crossed the Oort cloud some 70 000 years
ago
it passed just .8 light years away from
the Sun and then it made a turn in the
opposite direction without causing much
trouble
right now another Rogue star is moving
in our Direction
Lisa 710 has about 60 percent of the
mass of our sun and it's traveling
across the Galaxy at 52 000 kilometers
per hour
how long do we have before this Stellar
Invader makes its way into the solar
system
and what will happen when it does
if another star rampaged through the
solar system
the extent of the chaos it would cause
would depend on the size of that star
and its trajectory
when Schultz's star passed through the
Oort cloud it came five times closer
than Proxima Centauri the closest star
to our solar system
Schultz's star didn't have much effect
on Earth
although around the same time early
humans almost got wiped out by a massive
volcanic eruption
but that was pure coincidence
right
in any case before Schultz's star turned
away minding its own business
it did change the orbits of about 10
percent of comets and asteroids in the
solar system
but what if it was a bigger incoming
star like blizza 710 that's currently
making its way towards us
glisa 710 isn't scheduled to make its
first contact with the solar system for
another 1.29 million years
but when it does it could shake the
Earth quite a bit
at first the Rogue star would make its
way into the Oort cloud
at this point it wouldn't affect us
directly but it would send massive
chunks of Space Rock showering the solar
system
about 170 meteors comets and asteroids
would hit the Earth every day
that's 10 times more than what's
bombarding our planet right now
comets and meteors might not seem like a
big deal since most of them are small
and they often fall in unpopulated
regions but back in 1908 in Siberia it
only took one asteroid to obliterate 80
000 trees and blow out windows 60
kilometers away
if the same asteroid were to hit New
York the entire city would be in the
Impact Zone
all that if just a single star smaller
than the Sun Slightly made it just
inside our solar system
what would a more massive star do
well if a star larger than our sun
entered the Oort cloud it would disrupt
the orbital cycle for every planet it
passed
since there are such large distances
within the solar system this disruption
would happen over the span of millions
of years
it would be an almost slow motion chaos
of debris waves
it might even set some planets on a
collision course
and that's not the worst it could get
if the Rogue Star had other planets and
moons following it
our solar system would turn into a
galactic soup with stars and planets
being pulled out of their orbits
massive collisions would create a
Rippling effect disrupting planetary
orbits even more
eventually the Earth would be knocked
out of its orbit too if it wasn't
already destroyed by meteor storms and
the remnants of other planets
not to sound too dramatic but there are
estimates that 40 000 stars have entered
the Oort cloud at some point in the
history of the solar system but they all
came here on just visiting trips
chances that any of those Rogue Stars
will ever make it past the Oort cloud
are close to zero
foreign
how much water would you need to
extinguish the Sun
how would we deliver such an enormous
amount of water anyway and would all
that water even make it to the star
wouldn't it evaporate before reaching
the sun's burning flares
whatever your plan is be careful because
trying to put out the sun would only
make it hotter
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we extinguished the Sun
before we dive into how things would go
terribly wrong
let's talk about where we could
hypothetically find all that water
I've got some ideas how about the
universe's largest ice cube
a gigantic space fire hose
or an entire Water World tossed into the
sun
okay fine let's be a little more
realistic
no giant ice cube will be passing our
solar system anytime soon
that leaves us with one possible
scenario
we'd have to sacrifice every single drop
of water we have here on Earth
we would drain our oceans and deplete
all the fresh water too
then we'd build a very large fire hose
and blast it at light speed towards the
sun's core and then
[Music]
wait did I say there was just one option
I forgot about the possibility of using
a water world leaving the Earth with no
sun and no water seems a bit
unreasonable
and we could avoid that ocean draining
scenario if we found a way to throw an
exoplanet into the sun
but not just any exoplanet we'd be
aiming for a real life Water World
and we just happen to know where to find
it
some 40 light years from Earth there's a
planet primarily made of water with an
atmosphere of steam
scientists named it gj1214b
but we'll call it the Water World
this planet is 2.7 times bigger than the
Earth in diameter and it weighs seven
times more than our planet and it has
much less rock and a lot more water than
the earth does
there would probably be enough water on
the Water World to put out the Sun
forever
but it wouldn't happen the way you might
expect it to
if we were able to crash that water
world into the sun
the first problem would be the water
freezing in space
same thing would happen if we could pull
out a gigantic fire hose with all of the
Earth's water and aim it at our star
the ice would continue shooting towards
the Sun but it would face Mass
evaporation as soon as it hit the star's
atmosphere
the water vapor would then break down to
its basic ingredients oxygen and
hydrogen and that's when something
interesting would happen
the sun may seem like a huge Fireball
but it's not exactly on fire inside its
blazing core the pressure is 340 billion
times more than it is on Earth's surface
this immense pressure fuses hydrogen
atoms together making helium and giving
off energy in the process
since hydrogen acts like a fuel for our
sun pouring water on it would be like
throwing gasoline on a fire
you'd see the sun turn bluish white as
it grew six times bigger
it would create an extreme heat wave
across our planet but at least we
wouldn't be engulfed by the expanding
Sun although there could be other
consequences
we wouldn't be able to put out the sun
with its own fuel but if we fired enough
water at it at the speed of light it
could break up the Sun the pressure
inside it would drop the hydrogen
couldn't fuse together into helium and
that would shut the sun down
but with no sun to give us warmth and
light the Earth would turn into a frozen
world
after just one year Earth's temperature
would drop below minus 73 degrees
most of the plants and animals would be
dead long before that
and what about us humans
well in the deepest parts of the oceans
geothermal vents could have kept us warm
and supplied us with energy but we just
poured all of Earth's water into the sun
dooming ourselves to freeze
lucky for us the only thing in the
universe that can do any substantial
harm to the sun is the sun itself and
that would take billions of years to
happen
[Music]
imagine you were able to shrink the Sun
to the size of a basketball at that
point the Earth would be reduced to the
size of a sesame seed that's how massive
our star is but what if this fiery ball
of gas and plasma wasn't the biggest
thing in our solar system would our
planets still orbit the Sun or would the
Sun rotate around the mass of Earth what
would happen to our planetary Neighbors
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the sun was smaller than the
Earth
it would take the equivalent of 1.3
million Earths to fill up the volume of
the sun it's so big that it makes up
over 99 of the mass of our entire solar
system
it only looks small from Earth because
it's 150 million kilometers away
if hypothetically the sun was smaller
than the earth the earth would be
uninhabitable and the sun well this
massive Star May no longer be a star
foreign
Size Matters and so does distance
it just so happens that the Earth is
close enough to the Sun that it doesn't
freeze over like Mars it's also far
enough away that it doesn't get scorched
like Venus we're fortunate to be in the
Sun's habitable zone
this means that the size of our planet
the size of the sun and the distance
between the two of us is what's made it
possible for life to evolve here on
Earth
what would happen if the sun was smaller
than our planet
Mars Mass determines its color and
temperature bigger stars are hotter and
Bluer while smaller ones are cooler and
redder
the sun is a white star not as big as a
supergiant and not as small as a red
dwarf star
you might think that by making it
smaller in size it would just turn into
a red dwarf with a smaller habitable
zone but that's not the case
by definition a star whether it's a
supergiant or a red dwarf is only a star
when there's thermonuclear Fusion in its
core
how small can stars get well we haven't
measured too many red dwarfs at this
point but the smallest one we came
across has a mass of 10 Earths that's
very close to the theoretically
necessary size of a star to sustain that
Fusion anything smaller than 10 Earths
wouldn't be a star anymore but rather a
cold and dark Stellar remnant if for any
reason the sun shrank smaller than the
earth this shrunken Sun wouldn't have
the mass to create fusion and would burn
out completely
our solar system would lose its only
star
since the sun is the source of gravity
that keeps us all in orbit all planets
the Earth included would float away into
space in search of another anchor
that's no happy ending for life on Earth
let's try this again this time let's
make the Earth bigger than the sun while
the Sun's size Remains the Same
Earth's mass would be at least 333
000 times bigger than it is now a planet
that big would generate enough heat and
pressure in its core to become a star
itself
of course there would be no life left on
this hot star but here's a cool thing
our solar system would have not just one
but two suns it would become a binary
star system with two stars orbiting
around each other and planets circling
them both
in either scenario life on Earth would
have no chance to survive but life could
possibly evolve on other planets or even
the Moon
about a third of all Stellar systems we
found so far are binary or multiple ones
some of them even have stable habitable
zones
huh
a black hole is on a collision course
with our son and there's nothing left
for you to do except sit back and watch
the destruction of our entire solar
system
how exactly would this epic Collision
unfold
how would this black hole end up in our
planetary neighborhood
and what would it be like to witness all
this from Earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the sun collided with a black
hole
a black hole is not much different than
any other object that has mass except
it's dense really dense
all the matter it possesses is
compressed to an infinitely small point
at its Center called a singularity
most black holes are the remnants of
massive stars and just like the stars
they used to be black holes have a
strong gravitational pull
the more matter compressed into its
Singularity the stronger the gravity
there could be as many as 40 quintillion
black holes in the observable universe
many are located at the centers of their
galaxies like Sagittarius A star the
closest known black hole to us
it resides right in the center of the
Milky Way
but black holes could also go Rogue
after an extreme event like a collision
between two galaxies a black hole can
break free and start to wander
there could be 12 of these Rogue black
holes in our galaxy alone and one could
be headed toward the sun right now
if a Wandering black hole were headed
toward our solar system it would first
reach the Oort cloud
that's the sphere of icy objects
surrounding the solar system two light
years away from us
as soon as a black hole came too close
the icy bodies in this region would be
ejected from their orbits
you wouldn't be able to see the black
hole for yourself until it reached the
ice giants Neptune and Uranus looking
through a powerful telescope you could
see the gases being pulled away from
these planets
all the gases and dust torn from Neptune
and Uranus would form a region around
the black hole known as an accretion
disk this superheated collection of gas
and dust would orbit the black hole
making it visible
as it continued on its destructive path
you'd witness Jupiter and Saturn meet a
similar fate
you'd be able to see with your own naked
eye these gas giants disappearing from
our night sky
Rocky inner planets like Mars Venus and
Mercury would also be sucked into the
black hole and destroyed into
nothingness as you watched in horror
only Earth would be spared
not really of course I just wouldn't
want you to miss out on your front row
ticket to the destruction of the solar
system
as the black hole approached our sun
you might think it would swallow it in
one blazing Gulf
no instead the strong gravitational pull
would begin to pull matter from the Sun
just like a strand being pulled from a
ball of yarn
huge portions of gas would be ripped
away from it and they would spin around
the black hole joining the accretion
disc formed by the gas and dust of all
our neighboring planets this tearing
apart of the sun would keep going until
our star no longer existed What's Left
Behind would be nothing more than a gas
cloud only the very end of The Tail Of
This Cloud might be able to escape the
fate of being pulled into the black hole
as the sun's matter was being absorbed
lethal amounts of ultraviolet and x-ray
radiation would be released in fiery
explosions
this radiation would be hurled right in
your direction back on Earth
you wouldn't know the ultimate fate of
the Sun for eight minutes that's how
long the light would take to reach us
but instead of the light source of our
solar system disappearing entirely right
away the black hole itself could become
extremely bright
possibly trillions of times brighter
than the sun
and with the sun swallowed up the
stability of what's left in our solar
system would be completely destroyed
an entirely new gravitational balance
would need to be established
and in addition to all the lethal
radiation raining down on Earth extreme
tidal forces would push and pull at the
planet
this would cause massive earthquakes
volcanic eruptions and tsunamis
eventually Earth would crack into pieces
or maybe in the best case scenario
unceremoniously ejected from the solar
system
well the reality is you and everything
on our planet would be pulled right into
the accretion disk along with all the
other matter in our solar system so now
you'd have a new front row ticket
to the inside of a black hole
billions of years in the future the sun
will begin to die
and this is what our planet would look
like
but what if we turn things up a notch or
two
let's upgrade our star from yellow to
Blue
how different would the world look
could your body handle the increased
Heat
or would all life on Earth die
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the sun was a blue star
like any visible light sunlight contains
all the colors of the rainbow
but how we see a star or any Planet
depends on how hot the star is
the coolest stars in the universe have
temperatures of about
1750 degrees and emit more red light
while the hottest stars have
temperatures over 40 000 degrees and
look Bluer
our sun has a surface temperature of 6
000 degrees so it emits almost equal
amounts of blue and red wavelengths if
you could see the Sun from space it
would appear whitish
yeah hang on a second the sun isn't
yellow
yeah that's right the sun only appears
yellow to you because of Earth's
nitrogen-rich atmosphere red light and
yellow light have longer wavelengths and
can reach your eyes easier blue light
has a shorter wavelength and scatters
more giving the sky its blue color
but if our sun was a blue star you'd
never get to see a spectacular orange
Sunset again
oh and also you'd get fried instantly
now before making our sun blue let's
take a look at a couple of bright blue
stars that we know of
on the cooler end of the blue star
spectrum is rigel the brightest in the
Orion constellation
its surface temperature is about 11
000 degrees while it's almost twice as
hot as our sun rigel emits at least 40
000 times more energy and rigel's
diameter is 79 times larger than our
star if our sun was that large it would
swallow mercury and temperatures on
Earth would increase immensely
but why stop there you could turn the
dial up even further
if we imagine our sun on the higher end
of the blue star Spectrum it could be
like ETA karani with surface
temperatures of 40 000 degrees this star
is over six times hotter than the sun
but what's staggering is that ETA karani
emits one million times more energy than
our sun
if our sun was that hot it would be 5
million times brighter than it is today
violent ejections of plasma would Scorch
our planet regularly and the sun would
drench Us in Lethal amounts of UV
radiation
there's no way you could survive the
Heat
if you stepped outside for just one
second it would be like stepping in an
oven only hotter
the blue Sun would instantly burn all
the tissues in your body to ashes and
maybe even your bones
it would be game over for you
just kidding I wouldn't let you off the
hook so easily
okay let's imagine that your body was
super resistant to this extreme heat
there would still be that enormous
amount of UV radiation to deal with and
it would wreak all kinds of havoc on
your body causing your skin to wrinkle
age and get cancer
your vision would suffer immensely too
you'd get something like a sunburn in
your eyes the UV radiation would make
your vision blurry and your eyes would
hurt like hell it would be like snow
blindness except caused by the sun's
radiation
in addition to losing your sight the
blue light would mess with your beauty
sleep blue light suppresses your
melatonin levels with so much more blue
light and so much less of this hormone
sleeping would be tough
poor sleep could lead to high blood
pressure diabetes and even heart failure
the blue light would affect a lot more
than just us humans
outdoor plants would grow smaller
thicker and have darker leaves
high intensity blue light would promote
flowering in long day plants that
usually need at least 12 hours of
sunshine a day to thrive all the other
plants that don't like as much sunlight
would die
well you'd still likely have long day
garden vegetables like lettuce spinach
and potatoes but if our sun became as
massive as ETA karani you'd have heavier
problems than what to eat in your new
diet
the sun's new incredibly intense
gravitational pull would disrupt the
solar system
yeah you'd see Earth and all the other
planets get swallowed up by it instead
of getting engulfed by this massive Sun
you'd be lucky if Earth went a little
sideways and got shot off into space
then we'd live on a rogue Planet that's
not held by a star's gravity and roaming
in the universe
but we'd likely freeze up pretty quickly
and die anyway
if there's one benefit it's that all
this chaos and destruction wouldn't last
forever
instead it would end quite quickly
a star like Ada karini has a live fast
Die Young lifestyle at its young age of
about 3 million years it's already
nearing the end of its fuel supply it
could explode into a supernova sometime
within the next 100 000 years
our sun is about four and a half billion
years old and scientists expect it to
keep burning for another 7 billion years
so if we turned up the sun's heat we'd
be dooming our star and our planet to
premature death
not that many life forms would survive
to see that day
the earliest life on our planet dates
back to about 3.7 billion years ago at
that point our sun was already 800
million years old
back then if the sun burned as hot and
bright as Ada karani it would have
exploded as a supernova hundreds of
millions of years before there was life
anywhere nearby
so our lives seem better with the sun
burning at its current temperature
[Applause]
the sun's core is shrinking
but as its core shrinks the sun itself
grows larger
and it will continue to grow
until one day
it engulfs the Earth
how long can you survive
what will happen to the oceans
and will other planets be affected
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the sun swallowed the Earth
every one billion years the sun becomes
10 percent hotter
but here on what if we're going to take
billions of years and condense the
action into one month
get ready because we're going to be
moving really fast this time
instead of 1 billion years
it would only take four days for the sun
to become ten percent hotter
this means you'll see the Earth engulfed
by the sun in just one month that is if
you're still around to witness the final
event
on day one you'd be blissfully unaware
of the tragedy about to befall Earth
maybe it's a little hotter but that's
just weather it happens
but by day four space agencies across
the globe would be sounding the alarm
Bells
by this time the sun would be about 10
percent brighter and hotter
and while 10 percent doesn't sound like
a lot
it will be the beginning of the end for
us
as the sun heats up more and more water
from Earth's surface will evaporate into
the atmosphere
this will increase the greenhouse gas
effect causing global temperatures to
Skyrocket
all of a sudden it will become very
humid and very hot
foreign
but the sun's high energy light would
bombard the atmosphere splitting those
water molecules into hydrogen and oxygen
Earth will begin to lose its water and
you won't be able to escape the lethal
radiation on Earth's surface
if you want to survive you'll have to go
deep underground
but even under a protective layer of
Earth's soil you won't be safe for long
by day 16 the sun would be almost 40
percent brighter our planet's oceans
will boil and there won't be any
moisture left in the atmosphere
the beautiful Lush Earth that you grew
up on will become a hot dry Barren Rock
around day 20 the sun would run out of
hydrogen so instead it will start to
burn helium in its core
the sun is now a red giant star and
would expand rapidly while losing its
mass
the sun's gravitational pull on Earth
would be weakened and our planet would
begin to drift away from the expanding
Sun
but not far enough
according to researchers Klaus Peter
Schroeder and Robert C Smith the Earth
would only have moved about
0.0002 astronomical units
an astronomical unit is the distance
between Earth and the Sun
while Earth is moving away from the
encroaching Sun the red giant would grow
up to 1.2 astronomical units in radius
the sun would be larger than Earth's
orbit
it would swallow the planet whole
once it's inside the sun's atmosphere
Earth would collide with particles of
gas and spiral inward
and Earth wouldn't be the only casualty
of the expanding Sun
Mercury and Venus would be vaporized
the rings of Saturn would melt
Pluto would become much warmer and if
there is a liquid surface and a thick
atmosphere on this distant dwarf planet
it might even become inhabitable
unfortunately 30 days doesn't give the
human race enough time to prepare for
such a catastrophic event
[Music]
welcome to your new landfill
a giant ball of burning gas that we call
the Sun
with surface temperatures of 5500
degrees it could obliterate any type of
trash we throw at it
from pesky Plastics to nuclear waste
and with everything we're launching into
space these days surely it wouldn't be
too hard to send a little trash to the
Sun
but how much would it cost
what dangers would be involved
and why would it be easier to send a
rocket right out of our solar system
than it would be to get anything to the
Sun
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we sent our trash into the sun
our planet is filling up with garbage
yeah at the rate we're going by 2050
we'll be dealing with 12 billion tons of
plastic sitting in landfills
that's 35
000 times the weight of the Empire State
Building
sure it'd be nice to put it all in some
giant rockets and blast it off but there
would be some serious risks involved
like what would happen if there was an
accident while a rocket was in the
Earth's atmosphere and all our trash and
nuclear waste came raining back down on
us
the sun is about 150 million kilometers
away from Earth so getting any Trash
there would be extremely expensive
to put it in perspective the Ariane 5 a
modern European rocket has a payload
capacity of 7 000 kilograms and costs
approximately 200 million dollars to
launch into orbit
so to get all the planets garbage headed
off towards the sun would take 168
million of these Rockets just to remove
our trash for one year
the price tag would be 33 trillion
dollars
and that's just the cost of getting the
Rockets into orbit around the Earth
if we wanted to get them from the
Earth's orbit to the sun it would
require 10 times more fuel okay we get
it it would cost a lot of money but
that's just the beginning of our
problems
see Earth moves around the Sun at 30
kilometers per second
in a Direction that's basically always
sideways relative to the Sun
if you were to launch a rocket from
Earth straight towards the sun it
wouldn't lose that sideways speed and so
it would miss its Target
the only way we'd be able to get that
rocket right into the sun
would be if we could cancel out all that
sideways motion by slowing down the
rocket by 30 kilometers per second
how tricky would that be well put it
this way if we could speed up the rocket
by 12 kilometers a second it would have
enough momentum to get out of the solar
system so let's simplify that a bit to
crash into the sun lose 30 kilometers
per second to get out of our solar
system gain 12 kilometers a second
getting to the sun takes three times the
effort
for the sake of efficiency and fuel
costs it's better to go to the outer
solar system where the Rocket's speed
would be lower then use a little Booster
Juice to fire the engines enough that
the rocket and its load of waste would
fall into the sun
even if we were able to figure all this
out and successfully deliver our garbage
rocket directly to the sun it probably
wouldn't be worth all the risks involved
what risks you ask well for starters
let's say we've got our first rocket all
loaded up with a bunch of nuclear waste
and just as it's about to take off it
explodes on the launch pad
now we've got some fun nuclear fallout
to deal with
[Music]
but maybe we're a little luckier and the
rocket launch itself is successful but
it explodes once it's in orbit
the best case scenario here is that we
add a ton of debris to the already
growing problem of space junk circling
the earth
worst case scenario is that our
exploding rocket packed with thousands
of tons of household trash and spent
nuclear fuel comes crashing back down on
us
either way it's not good and this whole
operation really doesn't seem worth it
maybe instead of looking for these
outlandish Solutions we should just
you know stop producing so much waste
the sky appears darker the temperature
is starting to drop
our rivers are freezing crops are
covered in snow
people could go hungry
is it just me or is the sun dimming
are we about to enter a solar minimum
would this help fight global warming
but wait why are NASA and Elon Musk so
happy
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the sun dims down
the space rumors are true we are at the
beginning of a solar minimum cycle
and NASA expects it to be one of the
weakest in the last 200 years
so what is a solar minimum and what's
going to happen when it arrives
to help illuminate let's explain what a
solar cycle is every 11 years give or
take the Sun goes through a cycle where
the magnetic poles flip North becomes
South and South becomes North
during this period the number of sun
spots goes from low to high
with fewer sunspots on the sun's surface
solar flares and activity significantly
diminish
this is called a solar minimum
and it potentially affects the amount of
energy the Sun expels and its radiation
levels
this could explain why you found
yourself bundled up in your winter
clothes in the month of June a few years
back
the most extreme example of this
happening on Earth was the little ice
age that took place between the 13th to
mid 19th century cooling temperatures
disrupted the grain Harvest and created
an agricultural crisis in Europe
during this time temperatures dropped by
two degrees
NASA predicts even when we reach the
maximum level of this new cycle it could
be 30 to 50 percent weaker than the
previous period
that's leading some scientists to
speculate we are entering into another
little ice age for the next few decades
minus the woolly mammoths
now the flip side of this solar cycle
isn't favorable either
when Sunspot occurrences increase it's
called a solar maximum
during this time the sun emits highly
energized particles through space that
are potentially dangerous to All
Electronics and power grids
an extreme solar storm could wipe out
power for Millions if not billions of
people on earth
in a flash your phone's not working and
Netflix is cutting out the horror
intense solar winds could also cause GPS
and Telecommunications satellites to
malfunction would you even know how to
get directions without a disembodied
voice telling you which way to turn
recalculating even worse charged
particles could potentially shut down
essential life support systems and zap
the electrical functions in any
spacecraft that's home to astronauts
plummeting them to Earth
but what if the cycle permanently
stopped at the next solar minimum what
if we dimmed the sun down
could this cool the planet enough to
reverse global warming
well totally understanding the sun is
still a work in progress for the
scientific Community ideas about climate
change and whether solar Cycles might
contribute either positively or
negatively are plentiful
unfortunately according to NASA's global
climate change team the news isn't
really that glowing
they theorize that the warming caused by
human-induced greenhouse gas emissions
is six times greater than the possible
decades-long cooling from a prolonged
solar minimum
even if the solar minimum were to last a
century global temperatures would still
continue to rise
so maybe we need to start looking for
Earth 2.0 after all
but what does this mean in the short
term for our space aspirations and why
is NASA so over the moon happy
well right now NASA is working on the
Artemis lunar exploration program this
will put astronauts back on the Moon by
the year 2024 so think of using the
solar Cycles as predicting space weather
if you're sending anyone or anything
into space you want the conditions to be
as ideal as possible no surprises banana
good space weather equals low levels of
solar activity and radiation
if we can accurately forecast these
conditions
even years ahead we can better predict
when the best time to safely send our
astronauts into space might be
with this Insight we could also
Safeguard and prepare Humanity for the
harmful effects of high solar activity
at the very least we could secure our
vulnerable power grid during this time
continued Research into the relationship
we have with our star and the rest of
our solar system would be a huge help
for us on Earth
Humanity's nuclear Arsenal is capable of
destroying all life on Earth over and
over and over
maybe it's time we dumped it far away
now we might want to inhabit other
planets in the future so how about
our closest star
how many nukes could we throw at the Sun
what would be the price tag for this
mission
and could we accidentally destroy our
only source of daylight
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we nuked the Sun
the sun is mainly made of hydrogen and
helium the temperatures and pressures at
its Center are extremely high
so high that the hydrogen atoms fuse
together and become helium
that process releases enormous amounts
of energy that powers the sun it's known
as Fusion
and you know what else uses Fusion to
power up yeah that's right most modern
nuclear weapons get their destructive
energy from fusing hydrogen isotopes
this is why they're often called
hydrogen bombs or Fusion bombs
around 5 billion years from now the sun
will run out of hydrogen and die
a dead sun is terrible news for Earth
because we will die along with the star
now if humans managed to stick around
for that long we would be scrambling for
ways to keep the sun fueled and running
and if we were also still interested in
getting rid of our destructive hydrogen
Fusion bombs could we nuke the Sun and
power it back to life
well first things first we would need to
gather each and every single nuke on the
planet
this wouldn't be easy since the nine
countries that are known to possess
nukes are extremely suspicious of each
other but if the other option is the
guaranteed death of our only son
he could be willing to give up their
weapons of mass destruction for the
cause take my gun from me how big is
Humanity's Arsenal you might ask
well at least 13
000 nuclear bombs big
each of them with the explosive power of
at least 100 kilotons of dynamite
the United States alone is estimated to
have
650 bombs that are 60 times more
powerful than the nuclear bomb dropped
on Nagasaki during World War II
if you were overseeing this explosive
operation you would need to be extremely
careful after all you definitely
wouldn't want to have a surprise
detonation if every one of these Fusion
bombs went off the explosion would lead
to so much debris being injected into
the atmosphere that it would trigger a
nuclear winter
that's because sunlight would be unable
to reach the Earth's surface
cue the worldwide below freezing
temperatures ecosystems collapsing and
nuclear fallout
this accident would devastate all living
beings humans and animals alike
in trying to save the sun Humanity could
block itself from all of its Warm Rays
ironic isn't it
so yeah you'd need to Handle With Care
you'd also have to sharpen your
fundraising skills
if a modern nuke has a mass close to the
one dropped on Nagasaki sending it to
space would cost around
170 billion dollars
and that's just for one bomb out of the
Thirteen thousand
it's fair to say the whole world economy
would need to bend and break in order to
subsidize the survival of the Sun
and Humanity
even if you did come up with the cash
there are far hotter challenges ahead
like how do you build a spaceship that
doesn't melt as it approaches the Sun
the closest a spacecraft has come to our
star is eight and a half million
kilometers
even at that distance it still had to
endure temperatures of 1 377 degrees
Celsius only thanks to a thermal shield
made up of carbon composite material was
it able to withstand the scorching Heat
however we send our hydrogen bombs into
space it will have to incorporate a much
improved version of this protection
system so add that to the bill
and there would still be a mountain of
remaining technical obstacles like
finding the safest location to launch
the nukes into space
or developing the technology that will
allow us to Monitor and control them
from such a massive distance
but let's say you managed to do it all
our nukes are in orbit and within
launching distance to the Sun
this is it you send the order to fire
all the hydrogen bombs into our hydrogen
fueled star
now you wait to see how it begins to
recharge
just a little longer
a little longer
and nothing seems to happen
the anchor of our solar system
continues to die
but how
well has colossal as the power of our
thirteen thousand nukes might seem this
punch is nothing compared to what the
sun is packing
right now our star emits over 70 million
times more energy per second than all of
our nuclear weapons combined even if it
were running out of hydrogen to fuse
into helium throwing our hydrogen bombs
at it to feed it would be like throwing
a box of matches into a forest fire
you'd barely make a dent in the blaze
yeah that's a bummer but at least you
didn't destroy what little remains of
our decaying Sun if that was your intent
you'd need something with a lot more
Firepower meet the antimatter bomb
when the Big Bang created the universe
it did so with an equal amount of matter
and antimatter
is what you the Earth the Sun and most
things are made of
antimatter on the other hand is composed
of subatomic particles with properties
opposite to those of normal matter
put a little simpler it's the inverse of
matter
when a particle of matter collides with
an anti-particle of antimatter they
annihilate each other in a flash of
energy
if enough of those two camps came in
contact with each other it would lead to
a massive explosion also known as an
antimatter bomb
but here's the catch antimatter is
incredibly rare
if you pulled together all the
antimatter on the planet you'd end up
with only around 20 nanograms
a single nanogram is only one billionth
of a gram
that is so little that even if it were
combined with matter
you wouldn't even have enough energy to
boil a cup of tea
now you could produce more antimatter
but that would cost you
at least
2.7 quadrillion dollars for just one
gram
and remember
we're here to save the Sun not destroy
it
don't believe me well
see where our planet would end up if our
star suddenly vanished not even the heat
from all of those nukes would keep us
warm
but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
tomorrow
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Sun exploded tomorrow
that star at the center